we don't we just want him to leave he's
like Bill Murray from what about Bob
he's just never gone he's a failure a
week president I failed failed president
awful the liar is a fake liar a
relativist tyrannical I don't think he's
very good for our country right now
empirical when he related a message and
tricked a lot of young people doesn't
know what what it calls spade a spade
don't like Obama tyrants stinks and in
the tank we think she's in the tank and
stinks as well she's like Lady Macbeth
except less ethical we don't want her we
don't like her not not great a cynical
opportunist this is way too old she's
more of the same we don't support
Hillary at all whether or not she lives
or dies what difference does it make
I happen to love her kind of stupid kind
of dumb I think she has been grossly
misrepresented and the under s